[Music]
in [ __ ] up co-worker news ah do you
have a few of those now I'm gonna do
this like Joe Mickey I'm Joe Vicky you
know say y'all submitted by love from
Down Under
a man has died after his co-worker subs
a compressed air holes up his butt a
compressed air hose on compressed air
hose was this like a joke gone wrong he
died right you'd I don't know it just
sounds like a play to me okay two guys
played a boy
so there's a-- this forty year old
victim named Ravan the beardo Ravinder
reverend Ravinder like my mom saying
lavender lavender ribbon bow Ravinder
it's only reminder oh man not feel bad
what the [ __ ] okay what happened yes the
bushes I brother ever seen a man because
I feel like he got job respect
oh she yeah I feel like he got a job I
don't think no he didn't
so let me play no I don't know what else
to think they foreplay well I can just
tell you don't even have to think
exactly thing but I'd like to know
before things come to me okay
so this dude he was working at a factory
and previously he had helped out one of
his friends get a job at this factory
with him so now his friend is his
coworker and so revenger bent down to
pick up a piece of wood at the factory
and that's when out I'm John pick he
picked up the air hose
get up his butt and the fabric yeah how
hard hold that means really I don't know
if it was through the fabric or if you
pull down his pants they don't go into
details okay then what happen that's
hard to do
he ended up so by the way this air
compressor is used to cut through blocks
of wood oh holy [ __ ] so it caused
devastating internal injuries to
ravindra he died of hemorrhaging
hemorrhaging and organ damage oh it was
just a prank bro what how long has that
other guy been working there did he know
about what that was
did he or did he think he was supposed
to like I supposed to put this on your
book yeah he's probably just due to a
balloon oh my god you know like I want
to know like if he actually knew how
strong cuz he he worked every two years
also he murdered him then Dan what the
[ __ ] have you worked in another
department he just came over to visit
his homey and he's like oh [ __ ] air
compressor he's a part of the sanding
department yeah or maybe he didn't have
to put up the heart because if this [ __ ]
cuts through wood you would just have to
put it on you [ __ ] isn't it cuts wood
for shirt and go to close an [ __ ]
yeah cuz I was thinking like he ain't
even dared to be very Hospital leader
the worst death ever dude by that look
what's happening to John Robie peep I'm
John John I'm John I'm John well yeah
he's going to jail yeah
arrested him and that's all I know it's
very big very big Pam that's like well
he's probably gonna go to jail and then
I asked him what he did I tried to make
my friend and ever like we gonna return
the favor buddy yeah you know versal
jail prison things ah I feel like it is
yeah and so police are now looking
through CCTV footage of the factory to
see if anyone else was involved
John was a he's Logan Paul of India
oh right you like guys watch this I'm
gonna take this little cool hosting
spray my friends but see what happens
just a prank bro informations which is
the fact that he would regularly be
teased by wearing tattered clothing to
work so just like that dude get the
dollar - how was the guy who's more poor
than him biggie
bro it need be own friends with less
money than the other guy get a job yeah
cuz they're from the same hometown
what so it's a poor guy making fun of a
poor guy
well the workers would make fun of Ravan
yep it's for the poor guys again lavinda
the gut we don't know if the guy that
was that put the thing up his butt was
one of the people making fun of them
yeah you might have just because that's
some low [ __ ] dude you can't do that
dude that's [ __ ] tough dude they're
like how many holes do you have your
shirt today oh yeah one more are you a
Ford I have 505 old guy the workers they
also admitted that they would often play
pranks on Ravinder Aziz I picked on
bullied and said well yo and then they
picked on his clothes but that's like I
mean can we can we tribute to Ravinder
cuz I just want to look at him again
because when I saw him he look handsome
as [ __ ] yeah I think they were jealous
yeah exactly
because I think that's what they do over
there like he's kind of beautiful what
is this guy right had like the chick in
the hometown that other dude wanted I'm
gonna put this up his butt and I'm gonna
take his chick yeah Oh sabotage he
doesn't look like somebody you would
make fun of you know what it reminds me
of Big Bird huh Big Bird Wow
abra yeah like just this whole face is
very soft and kind like big bird he
looks like a nice person it's handsome I
think I think his those friends were
like the Mean Girls yeah cuz he's like
that light-skinned Indian - I'd like
that yeah there's a good general exam a
leak air compressor with the metal hose
at the end I need to get one of those
that thing is strong yeah why are you I
just want to cut lumber with with air
that's [ __ ] air bend you live in a
freaking high-rise I could use my
balcony you have one yeah oh pretty nice
lavender yeah poor dude for sure it was
out of jealousy because he's a handsome
[ __ ] I knew it yeah that's exactly they
give so poor coming around you with your
perfect skin is Ange are going to jail
it seems like yeah and they're looking
into to see if anyone else is involved
with that yeah they should put that
[ __ ] hose to jail to [ __ ] air hose
[ __ ] yeah because to get it in the
butthole it's not easy no that's that I
already said that so this is used to cut
lumber so you don't even have to put it
[ __ ] yeah well by then if there's other
people it makes sense
if they stuck it in there turned it off
second of all I think it looks kind of
janky to be able to cut lumber you don't
mean that that tool that you made in
India though it looks really small yeah
it looks like a little [ __ ] gas mom
yeah it's kind of cute oh maybe cut what
for like designs maybe well would you do
anything really tiny what would you do
if you found out that your little boys
were getting bullied and skew
oh he's too beautiful no cuz he's twice
the size of every kid in school that's
hot I don't know mad because in
elementary school I specifically seeked
out bigger people to bully to make me
feel better
like pull my hair all the time like
where it was like it would make me cry
and stuff I told my dad about it and
then one day my dad like he's picking me
up from school and I was like that's the
kid but that was like hey you pulled my
son's hair he was like and he just
didn't really say anything and he was
like do that again I'm gonna tell your
mom though he backed you up yeah that's
tight I think for me I would depend on
what the bullying is and if it's not
really malicious or really bad I I think
it builds character so I was like you
what are some ways that youth would you
intervene like like Tim if I felt like
he was really emotionally distressed I
would it's really mostly this but if
he's not I'm like oh yeah how is it
bothering you and maybe try to help him
walk through some thoughts have you
thought about kicking his ass yeah
that's exactly what I thought you it's
like you would be like I taught you
better than that you have a nice left
hook you better [ __ ] use that [ __ ]
strong good way mm-hm
kids are so weird man like I remember
this kid's name was Michael Jordan
that's dawg
oh damn like it's a Mexican kid though
but I go Jordan I think I [ __ ] sucked
the basketball Miguel horn in yeah eight
[ __ ] Cheetos in his sandwiches [ __ ]
like that that's not my name is Jordan
no just regular Cheetos and his ham and
cheese sandwich all right that was his
thing that's not weird its innovative
dog I'm not judging it for that I'm just
telling you my memory of him right now
all right yeah he's weird yes because
yeah wasn't weird cuz he would do this
one [ __ ] where he would like to flat
tire people where he was step on the
back of the tooth
funny he's a comedian so yeah well that
didn't end up very well from can I stop
him in the [ __ ] face your bully man
it was like one of those things too like
I just remember cuz my dad would always
tell me like you got a you know
Christian thing you know give people a
chance but then my dad is also Korean so
he was like but if he does it more than
once just punch him like he did once as
I hate me he did it again I was like
Amen don't you stop I just turn her away
right in the face and then you know oh
and then I got a bulb in the stomach you
know when they get the air knocked out
and I just remember he was just standing
him he was sort of beatboxing [ __ ] to
the office and they didn't hear my story
about him flat tiring me they just
thought I just beat his ass you're a
bully
cuz you did that often they knew you
already think I don't think that's a
good excuse though he still shouldn't
throw him you're a big mean bully but I
gave him two warnings though ice to stop
doing that he thought it was funny so I
thought there's some things don't change
pigmy yeah big means I haven't bullied
anybody I was the bully I was the bully
Ede and they played with fire and that's
a poke the bear and the bear woke up
mm-hm [ __ ] Cheetos boy
[Music]